autour d'eux le feu sacré les attikameks
prie pour que se lever du jour marque le
début de la fin du mystère entourant la
disparition de leur enfant dans les
années 50 60 et 70 des dizaines de
petits attikameks ont été emmenés par
avion à l'hôpital pour ne jamais revenir
mam à l'avenir dans le porte-bébé la
soeur de johan et martin dubé avait deux
mois quand elle été évacuée pour une
crise d'eczéma
mes parents n'ont jamais revu et en jeu
serait ce un coup de téléphone pour dire
que
enfin il était
tellement meslier jamais eu de papiers
qui vont nous prouver qu'elle est
vraiment décidé ni deux ni des ports
leur mère ne s'est jamais consolé de la
disparition de son bébé dans son coeur
le toujours que lequel était quelque
part il en a parlé pleurait souvent
mieux elle s'est cachée et je me dis
toujours est-ce qu'on meurt d'un examen
effectivement alors que bâle dossiste a
marqué guéri où est elle
j'ai un mélange d'émotions ans seulement
mélange de tristesse et de colère en
même temps les familles sont en colère
parce que les hôpitaux refusent encore
aujourd'hui de leur remettre les
dossiers médicaux de ses enfants
la très grande majorité n'ont jamais
reçu de certificat de décès ils ne
savent pas où leurs enfants présumés
morts seraient enterrés
quand on dit non chimiques ça veut dire
là d'où je viens
ça veut dire dans la forêt marie-lise
nico est affaiblie par le diabète a
perdu deux petits frères en moins d'un
an
en 1959 et se souvient s'être occupé
d'antonio un jour de septembre juste
avant de partir au pensionnat je l'avait
embrassée j'avais dit je m'envole un jeu
par longtemps je vois de voir seulement
au mois de juin quand je vois revenir
puis je l'avait embrassée fort puis je
l'avais dit je t'aime quand marie louise
revient chez un dix mois plus tard c'est
le choc
le gie chercher mes petits frères puis
ma mère m'a pris la du dépôt courant
ils sont morts puis moi je pleurais qui
est un peu plus dans ses bras aux pma
série bien fort les bébés nick wey
serait mort d'une même cause
étrange il ya eu un orage puis ça fait
que le lait qui tu es dans la bouteille
accueilli les petits
en bus les lots pis la suite d'être ceux
qui sont morts les parents n'y croit pas
vraiment mais nous pas posé de questions
au curé qui leur annoncent la mort
présumée des garçons aujourd'hui les
familles sont convaincus que ces enfants
ont été adoptés
on commence toujours que les quelques
parce que qu'elle a été vendue ou bien
dans quel est
je sais pas
[Musique]
les femmes y tenait à écouter ensemble
les conclusions de l'enquêté
très émouvant c'est très ému de
l'entente seraient des côtes et qu'enfin
nous sommes là en isère on aux époques
que jamais de l'espoir beaucoup beaucoup
d'espoir dans les coeurs des 10 heures
petits frères des parents des grands
parents qui ont perdu six enfants l'eau
moi j'espère beaucoup que mes petits
frères blanc je me le sol y revoir ici
sophie langlois à radio canada manoian